You are listening to radio lab radio from w n y.
S. E. Yep.
Maybe all of us can sit on the couch. You know, we can see,
I can rock and pull that chair over.
So we're going to start with a story from our producer,
Pat Walters about a couple, oh my word then it's okay.
So Janet, this is, I mentioned a couple episodes ago, by the way,
this is Jad Radiolab that we'll be bringing back some episodes back into the
flow from time to time episodes that we haven't stopped thinking about the field
truer to us now than before. Maybe the opposite, you know,
episodes that we still end up getting into fights with people about.
And a couple of years ago we ran a story about a guy named Kevin and a little
bit more recently. Hello? Robert, are you there? Yes. Great.
Jen will be here in just a sec. Robert Sapolsky,
a neuroscientist at Stanford who Robert Krulwich and I have had on the show many
times. Uh,
he recently wrote a book in which he makes an argument that really tries to kind
of just explode that story, uh,
in a way that we found sort of interesting.
It was just by a hunch that it plays near a lot of your buttons.
Sure does. So what we did was we sent him that piece, hadn't listened to it,
and actually what we'll do now is replay that piece and then at the end we'll
come back and a little bit of a fight about it.
So we're going to start with a story from our producer,
Pat Walters about a couple, oh, my word. Oh, that's the lady.
I'm Janet. This is the guy.
So I don't need you to introduce yourself. That's usually the thing we do,
but we're not telling people who you are. We're going to call him Kevin. Kevin,
yeah, yeah, yeah. That's, yeah, that's my name. That's suspicious at all. Yeah.
It's not as real name. That make sense?
Why we're not using his real name in a second.
Okay. You know, so this one starts a few summers ago. It was July, 2006.
Jan and Kevin were at home and, uh,
some people you don't know show up and maybe out start with you
when they show up at their door. So we were, it was a,
we were getting ready to go down the shore. It was a Friday. So we,
so we're in the kitchen and, and they come to the back door.
I thought the, I thought that they were fundraising.
I thought they might've been firemen just by, you know, the, the blue shirt,
the blue shirt, and then realized that, uh, that they were,
they were law enforcement,
two women and a, I think two men came up from around the, you know,
the side of the house and they show us their badges or are they cops or they
were homeland security.
They took me outside and they kept me and they asked me to stay in the kitchen
and they had a, a woman with me. I didn't know what was going on.
Nobody said anything.
What are they saying to you on the porch? Meanwhile, when the,
when they showed up, like after the door, you said, you know, while we're here,
I said, yeah, I do. I was expecting you
[inaudible]
and I showed him where everything was. Yeah.
This story about Kevin and his wife,
Janet inspired us to do the entire hour because one of the most basic things
that we do as people is we judge, we judge one another.
We judge what's right and what's wrong. But this story and the two that follow,
they will make you judge how you judge, or at least they had that effect on us.
We're calling our show
[inaudible]
blame. I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich and we'll go back to bat.
Before we do,
you should know that this show contains some graphic difficult descriptions in a
few spots. If you're not in the mood or if you have kids around,
you might want to sit this one out.
Okay. So what happened in that first scene and what happens next?
Only makes sense. If we go back a little first
about 15 years, it's just an ordinary day.
Kevin's going home from work and um,
I was driving home going about 65 70 in the fast lane when suddenly there was a
thump in my chest.
Then he just a heat boating. After that,
he said suddenly he had this thickness in my tongue and my throat than about
taste in his mouth.
Then my hearing faded out.
Any thoughts?
It's back
when I finally did come to, uh,
he sees his car is smashed into the side of an apartment building.
I do recall the officers telling, you know, you've been in an accident,
you've been at an end.
He remembers one of them insisted that he smelled alcohol and I was talking
through clenched teeth cause I had bit my tongue and uh, and my cheeks.
I was saying over and over again, I had a seizure, I had a seizure.
Kevin's got epilepsy. He's had it since he was a teenager.
But two years before this all happened,
he'd had surgery to remove the part of his brain that was causing the seizures
and it seemed to have worked. He was doing great.
Essentially wasn't having seizures anymore until suddenly you
lost your license. I lost my license for a year.
Things had kind of taken a nosedive. Like here he is, he's 35 years old.
I'm living with my brother,
I'm divorced and I have to call my daddy and ask him now to drive me to and from
work and you think I need to do something. This is not sustainable now.
Now don't, don't need that.
So I walked into the office as HR person where he works for a list of all the
employees, give me a list of everybody and where they're from.
So she pulled it up, I go down the list and I get to Janet Woodruff, Bloomfield,
only one. It's really close to me, five minutes away. So I walk to her cube,
knocked on the, on the wall and uh,
introduced myself like, Hey, my name is Kevin. I also work here.
I got this thing though. It's kind of awkward. I can't drive.
And I was wondering if you'd give me a ride. And uh,
she said yes.
[inaudible]
I really passed by his street. I mean on the way to work.
So it was right on history pretty much. But I made it clear, you know,
I'll do it when I can. And as they drove together, they started talking,
finding out little bit more about each other pretty quickly.
We liked the same music and that was unique because I sort of liked music that
was probably more in his error. Kevin was seven years older than Jan.
What kind of music were you listening to? Jackson Brown, mostly.
Lot of Jackson Brown. James Taylor just call um,
Bonnie Raitt. It's a little, you know, Elton John,
they found themselves
singing along to the lyrics.
You cannot sing with somebody day in and day out and not have something
happened.
We wound up as a spring came, you know, it's getting nice out. So now it's like,
well, let's not go home. Let's go out for a beer after work.
We're becoming good friends. We liked each other. For Kevin,
it was a little more serious than that.
I'm thinking about her and I'm starting to wake up at night and one day in May
as Jenna is dropping him off, Kevin turns to her and he says, Hey,
I really appreciate what you've done for me.
Let me take you to dinner just as friends, just as friends. Jen says. Sure.
So May 30th, 1992 Hailo and pavilion. Nicest restaurant. Yeah.
So your friends takes you to a four star restaurant.
You're thinking right away he thinks this is a date. We're going on a date.
Come on. So now on panic stricken, we have our dinner, we leave.
We had a wonderful time.
She drops me off and I handed her the poem. What did the poem say?
You still have it? Yeah, I do. Okay. This is a little slower. Okay.
Each time we sing on the way home,
I pray that traffic backs up so we can sing together just a little longer and
the harmony can go on forever and each time we reach my door I feel robbed
because we're always in mid song or mid thought. If only I could.
He gets out and goes inside and pry thinks, ask him. I gave her that poem.
She's going to be so smitten with me and you go home and what
want to throw up. I just thought, Oh God, you know,
next day I just looked at him and said, listen, we got to clarify.
This is clearly just going to be a friendship. He was seven years older than me.
He had these brain, uh, you know, surgery. He has epilepsy,
he's divorced. He has two children now.
You're catching the compassion here. Try. I'm trying. And he's just like,
I'm not asking you to marry me. I'm asking you to go out on a few days.
Exactly. If you go out with me like four times in the next six months,
I'm ahead of the game. He just handled it
and I don't think it was long at all. I can't even remember.
But it wasn't long at all before we were like a couple
[inaudible]
hey Kevin. Um, I'm dopey. Dopey in love. Oh yeah, yeah.
Doing romantic things for her all the time. Flowers, poems and paintings.
Illustration of the Jackson Brown cover. And within a year we were engaged.
But all the while Kevin is having seizures. Yeah.
Since the car accident more and more there was a point where we were obviously
dating. She's helping to make his bed and um,
he said she pulled off the pillow case covered with blood and one, two, three,
four, five,
six of you can count the number of seizures that I had in between my tongue and
bled.
I knew nothing about epilepsy.
I had never seen anybody have a seizure in my past.
Those would have been big red flags that I would have just walked away.
But I just went with it
and they both went with it for a few years until finally Kevin and Jan decide
this is enough. I wanted to be done with it. I just needed to be done with it.
So the schedule of brain surgery,
uh,
which sounds like a big deal and obviously it is,
but they had every reason to think that this wouldn't change it.
I honestly thought that he was going to come out of it fine. Better
cause that's what happened the first time.
Kevin had actually gone through brain surgery much like this one once before and
he'd come out pretty much the same guy. He was still himself. In fact,
he made sure of it. I had a, I was awake for the surgery and that's crazy. Yeah,
it was. I had to be awake, had to do with music.
[inaudible]
Kevin is a musician and the doctors told him, they said that if I lost anything,
I was going to lose my appreciation for music,
that it would be like music would be white noise. I said, you know,
no. For me music was no is part of my personality.
It was how I coped with my darkest moments in dealing with epilepsy and
seizures. At 18 years old, I'd have a seizure.
I take my harmonica and I'd find a place with decent reverb somewhere and be
right where I needed to be. I didn't want to lose that part of me.
So as the doctors were doing the brain surgery, they had his head open.
They asked him to say, you remember what you're saying? Um, into the innocence.
Some James Taylor and while he's saying they would tickle different parts of his
brain and if they ever touched the part that made him stop singing, they'd say,
okay, that's a part we can not take out. Wow. Yeah. And in the end,
I think they ended up taking out like four and a half centimeters, like a gall,
you know, a little bit bigger than a golf ball. Well,
but afterwards as he was recovering, I had my keyboard in the room, you know,
and I tried playing right away, Dah Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah Dah.
Okay.
And it works. The part of him that he really cared about was still there.
Exactly. Yeah. It was it man. I fell in love with after the first surgery.
So I thought, well, you know, now that you've got to do a second surgery,
he's already been there on this road, we're fine. And after that second surgery,
he did Tim fine. Janet didn't have her brother sneak my,
my keyboard up to the room again. He was very, very adamant that he wanted that.
[inaudible]
just noodled a couple of notes played a couple of things. And it was like, okay,
I'm there. It's still me.
I was ready to go to you go home and like it seems to have worked.
Yeah. As far as seizures go, we thought, okay, this is it. We're home free.
And uh, I was just happy to have some normalcy.
But then in the winter, by beginning in the middle of January,
Kevin noticed he wanted to eat my physical appetite a lot more than usual.
Got like insane.
This is a guy who didn't eat breakfast.
He had minimal lunch and he'd have an sensible dinner, maybe a snack.
That was it. But now I can eat the couch. It just was odd.
It was not him normally, but you know, you're like, okay.
She thought maybe it's just a side effect from the medications.
But then the piano
[inaudible]
I play the piano for hours. Same songs they used to sing in the car together.
He has stuck on a piece. He would play for hours. How many hours?
Eight. Eight, nine. And then there was sex, you know,
we were happy, healthy couple. Kevin's nodding. Yeah. Yeah, it was fine.
But what was abnormal? Was, it was, it was anywhere. Clearly. It wasn't like,
oh, we're in the supermarket, let's have sex here. I mean, it wasn't like that,
but I mean it was like I could just walk in the kitchen from being out of work
and he'd be like, Oh, you, let's go here. Which struck her as weird.
But then again, we were thinking, you know, let's try to have a family.
So the timing made things confusing and more than that,
it wasn't like any of this stuff was out of character. Exactly. In fact,
it was all stuff that she liked about him. Yeah.
Except now it was all turned up to 11.
All the things that were wonderful became chores
and that's pretty much where things are at.
When those federal agents showed up in July of 2006,
just completely blindsided.
You said, you know why we're here. I said, yeah, I do.
I was expecting yet Kevin took the agents upstairs.
I took them right into here where my computer was and they arrested him for what
was on that computer. I gave it up to him right away. Warning. Uh,
this next passage contained some graphic imagery. I mean I had hadn't,
I don't know if I had fully like I think I had just like let child porn be this
kind of vague thing that meant someone younger than 18,
but then I read some of the court documents and they were like toddlers.
They were picked videos of two, three and four year olds. There, there,
these sites had the most despicable,
disgusting things you can, you can imagine infants on throw,
um, you know, pre preteen and you know, preadolescence you know,
in a an adolescence it bought and you bought these things and put them on your
computer. I, yeah,
yeah. It, it, it bothers me. It bothers me.
Like I said, initially it was, you know, it was just your base, your basic,
you know, a Hetero Heteros, heterosexual playboy, like penthouse,
like sites.
And then windows would just start to open up and pretty soon he says he was
going everywhere there was gay sex. They were, I mean there was,
there was bondage, there was a defecation sex,
there was animal sex, xeno sex.
I went everywhere that a button came up to push.
I still don't understand it. I still, I still don't understand it.
He said it disturbed you and you feel terrible. I just like wonder, like,
how do you detail yourself? Like, that wasn't me.
Like how do you explain it to yourself to so that you can kind of, I dunno,
not feeling like you're as bad as the person who goes there
without a brain injury is, you know, like,
oh, I know. I say that again.
Ask that. I guess I'm just wondering, I don't know.
Like knowing that that's a thing that you did and it sounds like obviously you
know, that that was bad. It was a wrong thing and it's like a terrible thing.
Um, but it was, it was you who did it? Or was it not?
I don't know. You know what I mean? No, it, it was, it was me who did it,
but it was me with a complete lack
of neurological,
cool control, you know? I mean, I, I,
I know, I know who I am.
I did idiotic things that I couldn't stop myself from doing.
I didn't want to do it. There would be nights where it would be four or five,
six hours of going to the same site and and and downloading one or two files and
then deleting them, going back a minute later, downloading the same files,
deleting them.
I would download those files a dozen times and delete them a dozen times cause I
didn't want to be there and knew I shouldn't be there and couldn't help myself
from going back. I'm not an idiot. I mean I'm, I'm,
I'm a smart guy. I'm not an idiot,
but I know I had no control
and that's when he would argue in court, can we plead guilty?
But at the sentencing hearing he asked the judge to be lenient,
arguing essentially that the person who did all those things in some sense
wasn't him.
It was some other part of his brain that he couldn't control that the hearing,
he called one witness Devinsky.
I'm a neurologist and epilepsy specialist at NYU Medical Center.
He's been treating Kevin for decades, 2020 some odd years.
And he says as soon as he found out what Kevin had been doing had a terrible
sense of of responsibility. This is because of the brain surgery,
the surgery Orin recommended he have any argued in court that this was not
Kevin's fault.
I remember looking at those agents right in their face and saying to them and to
the judge, this could be anybody. This could be those agents, judge,
this could be you, this could be me,
this could be anybody and we would have no control over what we did and explain
to the court what the biology was
[inaudible] that the way the brain is organized,
that there are parts of our brain that are way deep down that control like base
desires like hunger. Sex keeps US alive,
but it's teaming with the nastiest thoughts.
We all have these crazy thoughts in our head now and most of us,
those thoughts are kept in check because there are other parts of our brain that
sit on top and act like a lid. But in Kevin's case,
the brain surgeon who did that surgery removed part of that filter and suddenly
the cork was off.
Yeah,
I mean it was just no lid on his sexual desires.
He said, scientists have known about this condition for a long time.
They first saw in monkeys in rhesus monkeys when the monkeys would lose roughly
the same part of the brain that Kevin lost.
They became very hypersexual males that would only previously be sexually
involved with females.
Now we're 10 times more sexually active with both males and females.
That it feels to me, feels to me like there's a,
there would be a brighter line before kids, you know,
I think there is a line for quote unquote normal individuals,
but in a brain disorder case,
those lines get blurred and he told the court that's what happened here.
It was black and white. Kevin was sick and his behavior was out of his control.
Well, that's not what the facts showed in this case.
This is Lee Barton who was the prosecutor. We saw no evidence of impulsivity.
He says, if you're claiming that he had no control,
that his brain made him do it,
then how come he had all this child porn on his home computer?
I believe it was 52 videos and 125 images,
and yet on his work computer there were zero images,
zero videos of child pornography on his work computer, and he worked a lot.
He held down a job. He was working every day.
If he truly lacked impulse control,
I would think you would see child pornography on both computers.
And so what he argued back was what was the lid on at work and off at home?
Seems to me to be an easy out.
So the answer is that this is common with neurologic disease.
They tend not to be 24 seven he says, take something like Tourette's.
Some people, when they're engaged in playing sports,
they tend not to have ticks,
whereas when they're sitting around bored or stressed,
they do tend to have text. So you could say, well,
Tourette's clearly isn't a neurological disorder,
but note Tourette's is a neurologic disorder.
We understand some of the brain things that go on Tourette's.
The prosecution didn't buy it. They just thought it was hogwash.
What was hogwash was his level of certainty,
depressed skis and asked the Kevin be sent to prison for five years,
gives him paying for child porn.
He was supporting an industry that does terrible things to kids.
Kevin hoped he'd avoid jail time all together and instead be placed on house
arrest.
This is a big Virginia. Um, right after the arrest,
I have to imagine that you were in shock a little bit like, yeah,
you'd gone to see a lawyer and
[inaudible]
one of the questions he asked was, is this marriage going to survive this?
And I said, I don't know.
And at that point understand I didn't even know the level of pictures. Yeah,
but she says the moment she heard orange say that this was a brain disorder with
a name called Kluver BST syndrome. Once I was able to get that from me,
it clicked like you couldn't blame it.
We have these experts saying that it was a disease and I kept thinking they'll
understand.
Not to mention that after Kevin was arrested and got an on bail or and gave him
some medication and Janet says it was like flipping a switch.
That's exactly what it was. It was like guy got him back. I was able,
I was able to sit and watch a movie with her, you know, normal.
Janet actually says in a lot of ways,
those few months between the arrest and the sentencing hearing,
they'd been the best months in the marriage. He now was just so much easier,
calmer. Uh, you could you just talk,
the hearing took about three hours and when it was over,
the judge took a recess, went into her chambers. When she came back,
she delivered your decision and we'll hear that decision when we come back after
a quick break.
This is Amanda Darby calling from Rockville, Maryland.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
sometimes what seems so clearly like the right decision ends up being one you
regret or you a really great expectations for how it took basketball.
I was boring to beat. Hi Radiolab listeners. I'm Anna sale, host of death,
sex and money from W NYC studios.
And this week we have stories of people with big dreams and big debt,
student loan debt, 10 grand,
80,000 7,500 $300,000 listen to the latest death,
sex and money wherever you get your podcast.
Hey, I'm Jad Abu Rod, this is radio lab.
We're revisiting Pat Walter story about Kevin. And when we left,
the judge was just about to render her decision.
She actually wouldn't talk to me for the story,
but I have the transcript from the hearing and um,
if you remember the prosecutor of the bar 10 was asking for five years,
63 months or in Kevin, Janet, we're hoping for house arrest,
meaning no jail time. There's no way they're going to put him in jail.
This is clear cut. And here's what the judge does. She says,
I do agree with orange. It is a neurological disorder.
No question do we can't be held fully responsible for his behavior.
She was getting it on the other and she said the prosecution did have a point
that he was very much in control of his impulses, at least some of the time.
And so the question for the judge was,
how does the legal system assign blame when a person is sometimes themselves and
in control and sometimes not? Well, this was a crime.
She said a crime, which ultimately leads to children being harmed.
And considering that you did have moments where you were in control,
then in those moments you had a responsibility, you could have done something,
you could've asked for help.
You could have told the people around you what you were doing.
So even if you couldn't have stopped yourself, they could have stopped you.
She made it very clear that we have to do something here. His sentence,
26 months at a federal prison and 25 months of house arrest.
Yeah,
and I, I believe, I believe that she, she was, she was fair
and I, I believe she was compassionate.
And about a week before Christmas in 2008 Janet drove him to prison.
How long was he in jail? For? About two years. And she was,
even though the judge said, you know, he is responsible.
Does that change her attitude toward him at all? No,
they totally stuck together. She visited him pretty much every weekend.
The whole time
I knew the route and I had my own little routine down in between visits.
She'd send up notes and I'll never forget,
he could send me mail and they had a store where he could get some cards,
super Hallmarky and he would like alter them.
And I remember the very first card I got, it was this very, you know, beautiful.
Supposedly it's supposed to be beautiful, but it was like, you know,
if you need anything, you know anything at all, just let me know.
And then he writes, of course, if it's pressing,
you might want to ask someone else because Oh well you can wait 24 months.
And I remember getting that and just laughing and then that became our thing.
Like, listen, this is a horrible situation,
but we're going to make the best of it.
Tell me a little bit about like where things are at now. I think things are,
are, are almost normal.
Uh, you know, I, I am still an on probation. Yeah.
But he's home. Um, he's working, life is going on.
We have our normal routines. Kevin's still takes those medicines that
keep the other part of him in check. I have no libido at all,
but I know who I am. I know what I am.
Um,
um, I'm disturbed by that portion of my life, but, um, uh, I'm trying,
I'm trying to move on.
Okay. Aw.
Pretty Pat Walters.
[inaudible]
so I know nothing about what your reaction to that will be.
It was just by hunch back
to a neuroscientist, author, Rebecca [inaudible]
simple scheme that it's of,
it plays near a lot of your buttons. Sure does. Yeah.
And No, while we'd always felt like the, at the end of the story,
the sentence that Kevin gets from the judge was this kind of interesting and
nuance balance between, you know, the idea that he had,
he just had a brain disease and the idea that there's some still some sort of
personal responsibility involved,
we'll right out of the gates and Polsky had a different reaction home appalled
that judicial decision and the underlying world view really.
Yeah, completely.
And for him it all centered around that sort of key argument that swayed the
judge.
That's some of the time he can control these urges and some of the time he
can't. The,
the example there was that never once at work did he do anything like that and
yet he obsessed,
we spent hours each night at home and the fact that he could control it in other
circumstances,
does that mean there is a separate knee inside there that's able to get to the
control panel some of the time but not others and thus that's
punishable? Yeah,
it's like he's in a kind of pitched battle with some inner urge that he has.
Maybe it's a biological urge, uh,
but sometimes he wins maybe in the morning when he's had some cup of coffee and
he's like nicely sugared up. But then at night, we all know this,
when we get tonight, we're tired, our brains are tired and we,
the aid comes out a tiny little bit.
Well, let's,
let's translate what you just said into sort of nuts and bolts biology.
Your frontal Cortex,
which is making you do the harder things when it's the right thing to do is one
of the most expensive parts of the brain to operate.
And when you're starting to get hungry or you're starting to get tired,
your frontal cortex doesn't work as well. And that's simply why,
uh, we have less regulation of our behavior in at night than in the morning.
And the perfect neurological example where nobody would invoke freewill in this
one is you look at somebody with Alzheimer's disease.
If they have early stage Alzheimer's disease, they show a Sundre,
a sundowner syndrome, which is in the morning.
They can tell you what their name is and by night they can't tell you in the
next morning, they can tell you again, whoa, are we seeing here?
Sort of a choice. Okay,
so they know their name and if they're not telling you at night,
they know their name, they can tell you their name in the morning.
And if they're not telling it to you at night,
they're choosing not to know what happens at night.
His blood sugar levels drop and the brain is tired and the frontal Cortex,
which has to do the like,
what was my name again with three and a half remaining,
neurons can't do it as well.
Nobody looks at that and says there's volition. Ooh,
they can do it part of the day. They should be expected to be able to do it.
But that's the address that that's because it's a different issue. I mean,
this is what you're talking about. Memory. Okay, so let me, let me,
let me,
let me go through a sequence here that I obviously prepared for the occasion.
Okay.
In the, in the Kevin Segment, they made mention of the syndrome that he has,
which is called the Kluver Bussi Syndrome. Right.
And this was first shown in the 1940 [inaudible].
You go into monkeys and you take out the same part of the frontal cortex as they
did with Kevin, and you get monkeys that eat themselves into obesity.
Now they can't stop eating.
They're hypersexual males trying to mount everyone and everything on earth.
Okay. Right off the bat we see some broad similarities. Aha.
You will say though, but Kevin has a moral system.
Kevin has Meta control. Kevin, as we saw,
could control it in some circumstances, but not in others.
We've left the world of blameless monkeys, far behind. Yes, yes, yes and yes,
goodbye. But hello blames. We have not,
you've got a monkey there who's got frontal damage and now is hypersexual.
He's attempting to Mt. Infants.
He's attempting to mount water bottles in this cage completely out of control,
but nonetheless, he doesn't try to mount the Alpha male. Huh?
Interesting.
Obviously what we have here is a monkey who has free will because in some
circumstances he could not do this bad inappropriate thing because he's got
freewill some there. No, that's ridiculous. Okay. Let's,
so both he explained to us today, it's not that he could control his behavior.
Some of the time it's that in this instance he was under the influence of
something else that he couldn't control.
Fear,
fear of the Alpha male activation of fear circuits override the feeble attempts
to lose four and a half remaining frontal neurons to state regulation in one
circumstance, but not in others.
Not because there's freewill or rotten choices or bad values.
This biologically broken system manifests its brokenness under some
circumstances, but not others.
And there's a logical biological explanation for why you get those exceptions.
Okay. Right.
You're talking about monkeys and one situation we're not yet. Yeah.
So let's take it closer to home now. Okay.
So you sit down somebody with damage to the ventral medial prefrontal cortex and
you put the frontal damage damaged patient.
Now in a circumstance where they're in a situation where there's a smarter,
more disciplined, better pay off thing to do and they can do it just fine,
but then you get them emotionally aroused over something or you get them tired.
They're horrible, terrible compared to regular folks. In other words,
we've just progressed from, okay, the monkey, if it scared of the Alpha male.
Okay, fear can override the neurons that it has remaining in there and they're
swamped. Now we've seen in a human, more in general,
strong emotions can override. So,
so far what you've told me though is sometimes I have the resources to choose
and sometimes I don't, but it's about the resources,
but the choice doesn't not exist.
It's just sometimes I have choose in their next step, next step, closer in.
So for my money, one of the periods for this,
how many rounds are we going to do here? I even have a clipboard here.
I've got it sitting in front of me. That's how much I prepared for this. Um,
okay, here's an example.
You take a judge and like this classic important study and you look at the
single biggest predictor of whether or not this parole board judge,
and this was of a whole panel of judges,
whether they will vote for somebody being paroled or not.
The single best predictor was how many hours it had been since the judge has
eaten what you mean that a Hungary judge will not give parole to someone but a
full and happy tummy in the judge will make the judge more gentle.
You look at this study and right after a meal a convicts had about a 90% chance
of being paroled and right before a meal they were down to about a 10% chance
that and it was a virtually straight line going.
Debts messed up and you know the single biggest Purdue actually looked the study
up and it turns out if the judge was making the decision right after lunch when
they were full, the parolees had about a 60% chance of getting pearls.
Okay. Not as bad as he said,
but if the judges were making the decision right before the next meal,
like when they were hungry,
the parolees had close to a 0% chance of getting parole.
What's interesting about that, number one,
the biology makes perfect sense. What are you doing there?
When you are a judge trying to judge somebody from a completely different world,
from you to reach your point of deciding there's mitigating fac,
you're trying to take their perspective.
You're trying to think about the indirect ways that you're using your frontal
cortex and when you're hungry and your frontal cortex is and is working as well,
it's easier to make a snap emotional judgment. This person's rotten.
The second amazing thing,
which exactly addresses this issue is you get that judge two seconds after they
made that decision. You sit them down at that point and say, hey,
so why did you make that decision? And they're going to quote on a no.
A manual contract. Alan Dershowitz at you,
they're going to post hoc,
come up with an explanation that has all the pseudo trappings of freewill and
volition and in reality it's just rationalization.
It's totally biological. No, no. That's what we're getting at.
You lose me on the word. Totally. Okay,
so it's met muchly biological, mostly biological. I might.
I might meet you halfway there, but totally no. Why does it have to be entirely?
Why do we have to go like
all the way?
Because if you're not going to go all the way,
here's the things that you're asserting.
I'm just going to jump in here because this part of the conversation got a
little dance and a long but suppose skis.
Basic point was that you just have to look at the sort of arc of scientific
discoveries.
500 years ago we would've said the epileptic seizure was like bad demonic
possession. Then Anna,
we learned that's biological up to the mid 1950s if your like adolescent child
suddenly started having hallucinations and hearing voices mean thought
disordered and you would say you the mother of this child would say,
where did this disease come from?
And the best of science at the time had an answer. They would say you,
it's your fault.
It was called schizophrenia genic mothering a mothering style that generated
schizophrenia.
You caused your child schizophrenia and then in the mid fifties the first
anti-psychotic drugs were developed and it emptied out the psychiatric wards all
over the country and everybody in the field said, oh my God,
it's a biochemical disorder,
and he says, the same thing happened with dyslexia.
We used to think it was just kids who are lazy. Oh,
that's biological also and his contention is that this is just going to keep
happening like as science progresses one by one.
All of the things that we think are under our control that we should control and
that if we don't, we can be blamed for one by one.
All of those things are going to get chocked up to screw ups in our biology
screw ups that we couldn't have controlled. Even if we'd wanted to.
You're going to have to do at that point is either say starting tonight at
midnight, there will never be a new scientific finding pertinent to this area.
We've learned everything there is or you're going to say freewill is just the
biology that we haven't learned yet.
Okay.
W when do you in your heart,
in your in and the EAP in the center of your like in that,
do you really believe this? Do you have
not for first, second, not for a second and that's the whole thing.
This is like my like huge conundrum.
I have like zero belief in freewill at this point.
Yet at the same time I cannot for a second imagine what the world is supposed to
look like with people believing there is no free will.
I don't know how to imagine it and I'm constantly this hypocrite.
I'm this terrible hypocrite because like I'll put on like my blue tee shirt
instead of my gray tee shirt and one morning and later in the day someone will
say, oh Whoa,
nice tee shirt and I'll say thanks. Oh my God,
the hip hop ocracy of it.
Here I am taking credit for it and that circumstance I'm not able to stop and
say,
well actually I have photo receptors that you know because of this gene variant
in that gene variant in my Rhodopsin genes so that I'm particularly good at
noticing colors,
sort of combinations and thus I can get the matching and I know,
oh I pick the fresh fruit here because my olfactory receptors allow me to like
be able to smell the pineapples that are fresh and the luck of my socioeconomic
status has me in life. Some like organic market.
And it gives me that like ability to do that while listening to like fake
Peruvian Muzak playing in the background. And No, you say when they say, Oh wow,
you really know how to pick good pineapples.
And I say thanks when it happens.
Oh this is like totally hypocritical.
A little bit of shade on the intellectual side.
I mean if you believe that every behavior, not just of Kevin's,
because what you're really saying is that the deep lesson of the Kevin Story is
that everyone is a Kevin. All of us are Kevin's all the time.
And that anything our worst and our best behaviors, yes.
That everything we choose to do is in some sense chosen for us that if you knew
enough stuff about anyone,
you know what they're about to do next. Yeah, yeah.
No, no, but I readily admit my flag and say, no,
I did not get on board with this.
This at least we've done it in a few realms. What do we are able to do it?
When you look, I'm, I don't want you to be a futurist here, but
when you look 500 years ahead,
let's say that the things keep progressing in the way that you imagined where we
just keep etching,
like sort of chipping away at this idea of volition and will free will.
What do we do in that point?
Do we not hold anyone accountable for anything but we simply prescribe
treatments in, I mean what, what, what does that world look like to you?
The treatments and or constraints you fix,
the things you fix and the ones that can't be fixed. You constrain things.
Who the damage can't be done, but it's done in a,
in a way,
a car with broken brakes is incredibly dangerous and can't be on the streets.
And if he can't fix the breaks, you put the car in a garage and
you know you've intervened,
but you don't invoke a concept of punishment of the car in there.
And if at that point you say, oh my God,
that's so dehumanizing to be that mechanistic,
that's a hell of a lot better than sermonizing people into having freewill over
stuff that they have no control over. And we've done it.
People with treatment resistant epilepsy, they're not allowed to drive,
but you don't sit there and say they deserve not to be able to drive.
You don't get like mobs of Gordy Russ,
Yahoo peasants cheering as the driver's licenses are burned.
No, it's not their fault that they have this thing called a seizure.
Nonetheless, if it's uncontrollable, they shouldn't be driving cars.
And we have a therapeutic intervention here that's completely outside the realm
of blame. Justice deserved, anything like that.
But let's go back to Kev at the end of the story.
Pat Asks Kevin what, what, what since he makes of his punishment,
I assume a that you wouldn't have punished him. Is that right?
You would recommend. Okay. But you notice what Kevin says. Kevin says, well,
I thought that judge was, was a good judge and was fair, fair.
He called her fair. So isn't it troubling to you that this person,
uh,
somehow was able to somehow feel blame worthy I guess.
But what this justice system is doing is it's sort of saying
you were bad. Maybe I was, I feel sorry.
I've got remorse. That's okay.
And now we give you your freedom back. Like there's been a,
there's been a conversation here, uh, about your morality,
your inner morality, but you do not apparently want to have,
I wondering whether that's a healthy thing,
healthy mental, healthy,
healthy or societaly healthy or you feel bad by saying thank you to your,
to your boot, to your shirt choice. So there is some human need here.
I don't know whether you might call it biological or not,
but there is something with the justice system is addressing that.
You seem to be, you seem to be taking out of the system and I, yeah,
punishment is pleasurable.
It feels good to do the righteous thing and it feels good to do that in a
punishing, blaming way.
If you're brought up culturally as most of us are to have this notion of like
agency, but I think, I think what Robert might the this Robert a two hour,
it might be a, I think Robert, let me know if you, if you,
if correct me if I'm wrong, is that it doesn't just feel good personally.
It's good for society on some level like d we want to live in a society where
the concept of justice has been tossed out and we're in a mechanistic place.
Well, how about taking it further?
Don't we need to have belief in a moralizing and punishing God because why else
would people be nice to each other? God,
I don't need to take it all the way there, but we have laws.
Laws are sort of in their way, godlike and that they rule over us,
so why not to send your rights instead of God? You're right. They work better.
As soon as you introduced the possibility of into economic games,
you evolve cooperation,
you do cross cultural studies and the more there's a belief in a punching hell
and the culture, the more generous people are in economic games. Yes,
that stuff works.
Yet over and over we've learned at least one domain where we've stepped outside
of all of that.
The epilepsy example where nobody thinks of it in terms of it being like just
this is being met out when the driver's license being taken away yet 500 years
ago,
somebody who would have been just as smart and just as introspective and just as
reflective and maybe even had like a nice bleeding heart,
liberal NPR tote bag would have said, it's really, I'm sad about this,
but have you told them to program? Nevermind. Oh my God. I called,
we were on Fox and that person nonetheless would've said,
this is tragic and I feel so sorry for their family and all of that,
but who told them to go sleep with Satan? Well, wait with live, let me, let me,
let me try it this way. Is there anything in the Kevin Pat Walters story,
is there any anyone in there who is being harmed or hurt by by what you heard
now? Well, he's paying a price.
His wife paid a price shame, imprisonment.
[inaudible] a terrible price here for what was simply a biological problem.
Hmm.
It's still very hard to imagine a world in which you don't get pissed off at
people who do like crummy things and where you don't feel vaguely pleased when
somebody says, Whoa, nice tee shirts. So what you just said is that the, the,
the, the feelings that you have about the story,
the loss to her of her husband time,
the shame of being put away for awhile.
You think that later on when the deeply biological explanation for this gets
fully revealed in a hundred years,
say people who will be listened to the story we just heard, I don't think,
if they only knew. Absolutely.
Hmm.
[inaudible]
big thanks to Robert Spolsky for chatting with us.
His latest book is called behave the biology of humans at our best and worst,
which has a, an extended argument about how there is no such thing as free will.
Definitely worth reading. It's called behave. Thanks also to Pat Walters for,
uh, reporting that story and, uh, for Kevin for allowing us to air it again.
And uh, thanks to you guys for listening. I'm Jada Boom,
rod for Robert Krulwich tonight we will see you next time.